ペットボトルに～
ある一定の量の水分をいれると
これくらいかな~　倒すと
（倒れる音）パコンッ
（何度も倒れる音）パコン　パコン　パコン
惜しい
（何度も倒れる音）パコンッ　パコン　パコン
（音がどんどん速くなっていく）
................
起き上がります（キラリンッ）
こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです
こちら
みなさん覚えてますでしょうか
おゆまるくんでございます
これですね大量のおゆまるを買って僕
一つの大きいスーパーボールにしたんですけど
それを更に変化させて
この人型にしたのがこの おゆまるくんでございます。
こんにちわ
（トミックの声）トミトミJだよー
はい。
ここはまだスーパーボールの名残があるんですけど
ぱっと見完全に、もうバケモノみたいな
で、この おゆまるくんなんですけども～
なんと、すごいことに めちゃくちゃ強いです。
めちゃくちゃ強い
ころころしてそうに見えるんですけど、腕とかへし折れないんですよ
なんだろう・・・すごい
ほらほら　ほっほっ
前宙できるじゃんもう
めっちゃ強いんすよ
ちょっと本気で攻撃してみます
はい。ということでご覧いただいたとおり
このおゆまるくん。
だっ！（攻撃）
あだああああああああ！！！
いたい！
めちゃくちゃ強いんすよ！
なんかイライラする
おゆまるの癖にすごい強いのがすごいイライラするんすよ
僕もですね、こんな最強の生き物を作る予定じゃなかったので
ちょっと詳しいんですよ！詳しくはねぇや！
悔しいんですよ！
なので今回僕が作り出してしまった最強のおゆまるの生き物を
ぶち殺...あっ...（咳払い）
ぶっ壊すために、
爆破してやろうかな、と思いまして
今日はこのおゆまるを爆破します
爆破しちゃえばさすがに息絶えると思うので
では、さっそく爆破していきましょう！
覚悟しとけや！おいっ！
覚悟しとけよ
うわあ
いよいよ勝負のときだなぁ、おゆまる
おゆまる(声ﾄﾐｯｸ))早めに撮ろうぜ
いいだろう
かかってこい！
(心の声)人目が気になるなぁ
はい、というわけで海まで来ました
フライパンを2つ準備しました
このフライパン2つで、おゆまるを挟めれば最高なんですけど
あ、いけるんじゃね？
あーいい感じいい感じ
おゆまる挟めそうですね
この2つのフライパンの中でおゆまるを挟んで
で、このフライパンの中に大量の爆竹を入れます
よし！こんなもんでどうでしょうか
2000くらいかな？
2000発の爆竹を準備しました
点火して、被せると、
爆竹に挟まれて、もう四方八方から爆竹2000発が体を襲いこみ、
おゆまるの体は溶ける、と。
彼はこれでたぶんもう、
さよならでございます
これならたぶんいくんじゃねぇかと思ってるんですけど
まぁちょっと今回は...
おゆまると俺の、男の一番勝負ということで...
♪～
(One more time one more chance)
行きま～す！
♪～
(One more time one more chance)
おゆまる～～～！！
お前なんて姿に...
おま...
◎△＄♪×￥●＆％♯？！(おゆまるっ！？)
(泣くはじめしゃちょー)
おゆまる)ふぇえ！！
生きてるんかーい
ダメか。爆竹でも倒せねぇか...
それより掃除しなきゃ...